[Applause]
one cup of tea please
thank you
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
there are 135 000 stalls here and i hear
it's the best street food in india
what is it potato
very good
in fact it's delicious
[ __ ] spicy
i can't believe the variety on offer egg
sandwiches
calcutta's very own predamore
fascinating high noodles yeah noodles
noodles
so it's chicken noodle vegetable chili
sauce a little bit of tomato sauce on
there
it's very good
and everything is prepared from scratch
right here on the street
just the level of the basic food on this
street is of a delicious nature
and you've got like this gourmet trail
starting from the back like a little
canopy with the eggs and then you go
down to the vegetable then all of a
sudden you hit the meat right at the
very end and then finish with the
desserts there's not a street like
anywhere in the world i'm on a culinary
adventure through india and i've
traveled into the wilds of the northeast
where i'm on the trail of india's best
kept culinary secrets
[Music]
i've just arrived in nagaland where i'll
be staying with the cognac tribe and i'm
the first western chef they've ever met
hello
this is my father gordon sir how are you
your father's name uh what do i what do
i call him
mr
it's very kind thank you very much
thank you very much
that's amazing i know all these people
here these are our relatives and
villagers you say hello hello hello
[Applause]
what is that
this is all ball yeah
and what these bits here
uh these are uh intestines intestine and
we eat them as well yes yes it's not
numbers
the tribe might actually enjoy meat more
than i do
for jin's father has even got a version
of one of my favorites on the go
so it's like a
blood sausage like a black pudding
wow look at that
black pudding
that is delicious
that is very good
we don't put chili in our blood sausage
blank pudding back in the uk
you think of any authentic indian food
you never ever
think about black pudding but that's
just
completely different thank you
and a great cup of tea as well
this is how we eat in scotland yeah
black pudding
yeah
and tea
he said that because he's
good looking and handsome like he has
got three wives
oh jesus what about you
yeah those laws don't apply in ones
worth the news the world would love that
one
he said why don't you come with him
tomorrow for the hunt
i would love to go hunting he is
inviting you i thought it was banned no
no no this is tribal land we are the
owners of alain right and we have every
right to hunt to hunt yes and that's how
the village survives yes
to think that
50 60 years ago
there was tribal
gangs
warfare revenge and any way to seek
revenge was beheaded
your victim
and that's that's that's not [ __ ]
about now i mean that's pretty uh
so they all may look nice and smiley and
high fives and how you doing
sit down have some black pudding and a
cup of tea but you want to [ __ ] with
them in the jungle would you
now for the real reason i'm here i'm
going to see what makes a nagaland curry
so different to anything i've ever
tasted before
as i've been gifted the venison mr honly
is going to create a curry using the
boar that he slaughtered
so
in there a kidney kidney
are you cooking everything at the same
time see normally
we'd cook this separately it's very
rustic nothing's filleted nothing's ever
off the boat
and what's that dad's putting there my
father is uh putting another kind of
leaf which you find in the forest and
what's it like
thank you
it's quite citrusy huh yeah yeah it's
like lavender we use even the fruits for
like pepper
everything mr holly is using in his dish
comes from his own land this is the
first indian curry i've seen made
without any dried spices
what's that doing with the chilis he's
uh roasting it
we have a better flavoring if we roast
it on the ash like that yeah it gives a
better scent yeah but we do the same
with peppers
and the most surprising ingredient is
something i've never seen before
it's bamboo shoot
yeah that's a fascinating smell you know
that
slightly spicy edge to it
while the pork and the bamboo curry
cooks i'm gonna try out these nagaland
ingredients with my saddle of venison to
see what i can come up with
pure fillet
just a little touch they intrigued me
the flavor there you know
[Music]
how do you turn up the gas
[Music]
thank you
how many westerners have come and
cooking this kitchen
none no
i'm the first
[Music]
it's a tradition in scotland we always
have a swig each oh yes
it means our passion is joined with the
dish
while my venison curry reduces mr
honly's pork and bamboo curry is already
done and i can't wait to taste it the
pork is delicious
very tasty the chili the garlic
and it looked quite sort of
boring and greasy
but flavor-wise
delicious
that's delicious the pork
the villagers from today's hunt that
didn't get a cut of the deer came to
share mine
very nice
[Music]
yes
jordan yep can you just give them a
second of course
there's real community spirit here and
it makes eating together all that more
enjoyable
the pork dish i tasted of theirs was
amazing you'd think that there was 15
different spices the dried bamboo in
terms of flavor it's intense yeah it has
an intriguing sort of turnip stroke
cardamom
sort of slightly spicy
edge to it who'd ever believe we're in
india no spice
no turmeric yeah no coriander no
cinnamon no clothes everything's just
yeah from the ground
it's quite interesting you dive into
their world and you get rid of that
monkey on your back and all of a sudden
you start to relax in a big way
and forget
anything outside this village
[Music]
has a massive appetite for them
today she's attempted to break her own
world record for eating 60 whole chilis
in two minutes
this is no ordinary chili and andita
will be munching on the boot jolokia
yeah
the whole the whole the whole thing but
don't eat it don't don't eat it don't
eat it
just take whatever he's taking them to
have a bite but not to eat it not to
chew it it'll be very
hot
this baby is 200 times hotter than a
jalapeno
it's a chili nuclear bomb
[Applause]
that's very hot yeah one is enough very
very hot indeed
my mouth's still burning on a little
piece of one
[Laughter]
good luck
so here we go
i'm playing safe by being timekeeper
ready
three two one go
ten seconds gone
oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[ __ ] excuse me
two minutes dead stop
oh jesus she's gonna be sick get some
water for the lady quickly
oh my god
how many is left
how many deaths 17 19
andita has decided to up the ante
she's going to try to rub more than 12
chillies in her eyes in under one minute
how many is that
30.
ready 3 2 1 go
[Music]
fifteen seconds gone
come on you little wake up
[Applause]
[Music]
30 seconds gone
come on
15 seconds to go you got six left
five
four
three
two
[Music]
[Applause]
congratulations well done really well
done
i think you are mad
excellent
i mean those chillies were extraordinary
hot i mean unbelievably hot just biting
into one it just sort of exploded and
all of a sudden your mouth went on fire
but it's a very bizarre thing to witness
she's off a trolley
a confirmed nut
you